Вакансій багато, та жодної із гідним заробітком,
каже 46-річний Володимир Миколаєнко.
Тож вони з дружиною вирушили на так званий
"фестиваль вакансій для ветеранів АТО" в Києві.
Батько трьох дітей хотів би влаштуватись на роботу водієм, але офіційно.
Адже відтоді як повернувся з фронту -
2 роки підробляє таксистом на орендованій машині.
Можливо, щось буде. Якийсь водій в офіс.
Можливо, для керівника.
В таксі я вже не можу прокормити сім'ю.
Я сутки-двоє працюю, але все одно цього не вистачає.
Фестиваль вакансій для ветеранів АТО організували
кілька громадських організацій Києва та Державна служба зайнятості.
Держслужба пропонує кілька тисяч вакансій в Києві і області для колишніх вояків.
Пропозицій від роботодавців за останній рік побільшало на 30 відсотків.
Цьому сприяли нові зміни до законів,
що заохочують підприємства брати ветеранів.
Але якість пропозицій не покращилася - це здебільшого робочі спеціальності на Київщині
з середньою зарплатнею у п'ять тисяч гривень.
Для Ярослава - це взагалі не варіант.
Після фронту він продовжує навчання в медуніверситеті,
постійно знаходячи якісь підробітки.
Нормальної ж роботи за своєю спеціальністю санітара він поки не знайшов.
Держсектор платить замало.
Приватний- не бере на себе соціальних зобов'язань.
Немає ніякого, як-то кажуть, соцпакету.
Можна ж було б лікарняні давати.
Адже людина не може ж бути постійно на роботі. Правильно?
З ранку до ночі працювати на роботодавця і отримувати копійки.
За даними Держстату, на ринку праці України в середньому
на одну вакансію претендують 5 безробітних.
Тож роботодавці можуть обирати.
Колишніх "атошників", яким треба періодично лежати у лікарнях
зі своїми фронтовими пораненнями чи то каліцтвами, беруть на роботу лише в останню чергу.
Це підтверджує і Сергій Молодід.
На його думку, склалася ситуація,
коли ані ветерани не підходять роботодавцям, ані роботодавці їм.
Всюди є якісь нюанси. Там зарплата в конвертах.
Там якийсь варіанти з екологією, там шкідливо для здоров'я.
Просто, можливо, до війни люди готові були з чимось миритися.
Після того, як вони пройшли війну, вони стали більш принциповими.
Для себе це питання Сергій вирішив, відкривши власний бізнес.
І тепер виробляє військове спорядження.
Таких ветеранів-підприємців, лише за допомогою Держслужби зайнятості,
яка виділяє гроші для старту бізнесу, за останні два роки з'явилося близько двох тисяч.
Володимир Миколаєнко на фестивалі вакансій нічого для себе не знайшов.
Можливо, він теж поміркує про власний бізнес.
Дружина Катерина готова до будь-яких ініціатив чоловіка.
Каже, дуже важко підтримувати його позитивний настрій.
Боїться - аби поразки в цивільному житті знов не змусили його повернутися на фронт.